[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture,
we open a new chapter
of weak interaction.
So we are one by
one adding together
the components we need
in order to describe
all elementary particles
and their interactions.
And I'll be adding the
third form of interaction.
After the QED and QCD, we
enter into the discussion
of the weak interaction.
So let's have a look
at the standard model.
So we discussed gluons and QCD.
And we saw that gluons
couple to themselves and also
to all quarks.
Because they carry
a charge under the--
on the QCD, a color charge.
We have also
discussed the photon,
and seen that the photon, they
do not couple to themselves,
but they couple to all
charged elementary particles.
Those are the meta
particles, the fermions.
The photon also
couples to the W boson.
We call it the
electrical charge.
So now what we want to
do in this next chapter.
We want to fully understand
the W and the Z boson.
And we will see that they
couple to all meta particles.
And we'll also discuss how they
might couple to themselves,
or the Z boson couples
to the W boson.
Well, that's the story
of this entire chapter,
and we'll take it one by one.
As an introduction, we start
with the Feynman Rules.
So having the Feynman Rules
in place, and the cookbooks,
the recipe, in order to
calculate decays and scattering
processes.
That is all we need in
order to get moving.
You can, for example,
look at this vertex
here, of this component
of the Feynman diagram.
And what we need
to analyze this is
the propagator for the W and Z
boson, and the vertex factor.
This vertex factor
now looks a little bit
more complicated
than for QED and QCD,
because the W boson and the
Z boson, they carry mass.
So we have some additional
factors. q squared minus M
square.
And this q squared over
M squared term as well.
One interesting fact
about this vertex factor
is what happens now, is q
squared is much, much smaller
than M squared.
We have to get rid of
those components here,
and we find a
vertex factor which
looks similar to the
one we have in QED.
However, that's not one over
q squared term, but 1 over M
squared term, which is constant.
So we would see
that we can describe
this in the context
of the Fermi theory,
which is a lower
energy approximation
of the full theory
of heat conduction.
It's kind of an
interesting concept,
and it extends to the
entire understanding
of the standard model.
It might be that
our standard model,
you know, that we have
all the packages together,
describes the lower
energy approximation
of a more complicated-- more
holistic theory, which we then
can discuss under the concept
of a grand unified theory.
Maybe there's a
symmetry group which
is embedding the symmetry
groups we need for QED, QCD,
and the weak interaction.
But that's a side remark.
So we will look at the Fermi
Theory a little bit more later.
The vertex factor itself,
describing the vertex here.
It's given here.
For the W boson, and
also for the Z boson.
And it looks a little bit more
complicated than the vertex
factors we have seen so far.
What you notice that
there is the parameter,
which is associated to the
strength of the interaction.
And the gamma matrix.
But there's also this term
here, which has two components.
There's the one, and
the gamma 5 matrix.
We have talked about
gamma 5 matrix already.
And we can later identify
those as individual currents
are coupling to vector current
and an [INAUDIBLE] current.
So this looks even
more complicated
now for the Z boson,
because here we
have not just numbers of one,
but an additional factor.
This factor cV is
a vector coupling,
and it's specific
for each fermion.
So each fermion has
one of those constants.
And the second part of the
package or set of constants,
for the axial current.
You have a second
parameter here,
which is the strength of
the coupling of the Z boson.
So at this point, you
just take this axial,
and you can do all
our calculation.
On our next slide,
I'm going to explain
to you what the corresponding
numbers and what d values are
for those parameters cV and cA.
Later, we will see how it
comes to this more complicated
structure, and why
there is a vector,
and why there is an
actual axial current
in the weak interaction.
But for now, we just
take this for granted,
and we just take
this as a recipe.
So now for the neutral.
So we've just have seen that
this is the vertex factor.
And here, for all
fermions, we list what
these values are for cV and cA.
What you can see is
for the neutrinos,
the factor is one half,
both for cV and for cA.
And for the charge
leptons and quarks,
there is an even more
complicated term here,
which includes a new parameter.
Sine squared theta w.
The value of this is 28 degrees.
Sine squared theta w is 0.231.
As a little bit of a
preview here already,
the fact that there is this new
parameter and an angle involved
leads to, or can
be explained later,
by the fact that the weak
interaction is actually
a result of a mixing between
an original weak interaction,
and QED.
So there's a mixed
thing going on.
In other words,
the Z boson itself
is a mixture between
the thing which
couples to the weak
part of the particle,
and the part, which
couples to the electrically
charged part of the particle.
When you see that,
that's why there
is a simple factor for the
neutrinos who are electrically
neutral, and a more complicated
term here for the electrically
charged particle.
And you see that this is
the electric charge here.
Or two times the electric
charge of the particles.
But for now, those are all
just constants and recipes
to be used.
One additional
word on the history
of the neutral charge of
the neutral weak current
is given here.
So in the '60s and
'70s, the standard model
was slowly developed.
A little bit more slowly than
we do in this class here.
And there was--
the hypothesis is
that there have to be something
like a neutral current
in there.
But it has never been
observed in nature.
And so this bubble chamber,
specifically the one
Gargamelle at CERN, one was
able to actually see those, see
virtual and really
see, those interactions
for the first time.
And the first pictures that have
been taken in the 1970s, 1973.
And this picture
here illustrates--
I will expand it in a second--
illustrates the
interaction of a neutrino
coming into the bubble
chamber, making an interaction
with an electron, and then
scattering off, kicking off
the electron.
So what you see here
is this incoming--
this is an anti-neutrino
kicking off an electron.
See the electron here.
The neutrino goes
off undetected.
It just disappears.
You see here, the electron.
And then there's
also two protons.
One proton here.
Let's use a different color.
And one photon here.
Causing electron positron
pair, and the second photon
here doing the very same thing.
You can see those
particles here.
See here and then
going on here as well.
So this is a bubble
chamber picture.
We'll talk about bubble
chambers very briefly
later in the lecture as well.
But they're very extremely
important and useful tools
in order to illustrate--
to visualize and measure
particle interaction.
All right.
So much to the
introduction, and we'll
continue now with the
next lecture on talking
about this mixture, this
electroweak mixture [INAUDIBLE]